hello welcome back to big mood we are
here doing another Zuma episode hope you
guys are enjoying these um we switch it
out this time we're all in different
very fancy locations very very fancy a
look at maddest I am in that too if
you're not watching on YouTube TIFF is
in Paris reporting live from yes it's
empty the background so you know it's
dark orange a pendulum what is she
wearing
she's wearing her for her second wedding
dress not the first one right though not
the Chinese one she's delivered once oh
please this is my third dress actually
had one for the court wedding and then
the ceremony dress and then now the
Paris dress she's a bougie ass [ __ ]
alright and then your bows in heaven an
Angels outfit we are angel damn I gotta
earn that on it did you see that the
dimple is strong today I wanna check it
out did you only get shows in heaven
that's how you know it's legit and then
we have a Gina and a whole Breakfast at
Tiffany's outfit in her palette love it
Mike huh I'm upset she's quitting this
is a palace there's nobody walking in
the hallways welcome to my room if you
see here right here this is my my help
hahaha there is a person there to crown
polish' great polish is it with his
tongue you guys it formal I'm [ __ ] do
formal do we okay yeah it slightly
sludgy you in today today is our formal
day we decided to do themed podcast
episode days and today's formal and Gina
took it very seriously
yeah yeah I heard we turned on a camera
but I guess we have our wedding dresses
oh honey well I feel like when I got in
everyone turn on their cameras and I was
like Gina what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm looking fabulous that's my bid do
you got one brand how dare you my crown
and I just want to say Nikki you hold on
Nikki what do you wear yeah I'm wearing
my wedding dress I'm in the I'm in an
archway and I love it it feels like
sweatpants that's what I love about my
what I love is it see me you big is this
super comfy actually like now that we're
quarantined like I've been trying to be
a better person I believe in like being
humble you know like not being so extra
I think it really really really changed
my life you know and they like this like
beneath you guys do you just had someone
pour her wine from off-screen but still
very humble in a very humble way but a
very humble one for sixteen rings today
I'm only wearing eight oh my gosh you
are taking a sacrifice can so sweetness
no so my review music 8 rings off for
charity they didn't give them to charity
she just took him off but honor charity
just to show what she look would look
like if she had less jewelry she's just
like any of us okay so relatable and I
love a little I mean because I
quarantine like this a whole tiny new
quarantine routine that we're doing now
I'm trying to be a better person
yes how are these quarantine routines
going because for me I need a routine or
else every day blends into each other
everything feels the same and then I
slowly dwindle into a black pit of
anxiety so I think you tell them what
you did yesterday Animal Crossing with
me oh my god yesterday Gina's island so
I needed to sell my cherries I didn't
have anybody to go to but also any wood
because um because I because I love Gina
oh and I also had a drop off a [ __ ]
bed for her because how was the
sleepover hot still she's so far in the
game
I thought she saw a tent or something
maybe no she's completely advanced her
talent but still an empty ass house with
a car which is not dissimilar to her
actual house it is like a bachelor pad
but this is my bachelor pad the sexual
one my lesser houses oh yeah sorry I was
talking about your second home oh oh
sorry the only roommates this is the one
you had my 14th one this is when you
know like if this is my vacation home
but currently I'm at my humble home at
Gino's real house she has a box
she's a bed in a box on her floor and
then and then what happened oh yeah so I
dropped off a bed for her Island and a
kitty litter box I don't have a whole
bunch of [ __ ] on her Island and then her
whole island is covered with weeds like
TV and weeds EXOR just started cleaning
nightshift I could not handle it I would
let you give me some oranges for this
eyelid just pick it up wigs cleaning up
the cutest feels like a girl let her go
she came over like my mother like I
bought you a bed a little Austrian cat
and then we clean up all the ways and
your [ __ ] law I wish you can have a
cat or a dog and animal crossing that
would be so cute me too I look kind of
hot no actually I would yeah because
like cats like live on your Island like
as humans yeah there's like a human cat
I neighbors
it would be weird if like you had a
human cat resident or like a cat
resident but then you had like a cat in
your house like this is the dumb one
[Music]
that's what he though like we got it's
like cuckoo food yeah exactly
dude it took me so long to realize that
goofy was a dog did you think I got a
cow I thought he was a cow I thought he
was a person i I just actually actually
tweet of this where like I realized that
goofy was a dog and I was like because
he's mind-blowing to me in your mug
that's really cute it's a donut that's
really cute I want one yeah so oh my god
see we can't
it's practically um no it's just washer
safe so I just put in the top rack nice
nobody has a dish wash I mean yeah nice
dish wash well she's good too
I also have a dishwashing grab a human
in dishwasher 46
actually washes and one dish to the
human dishwasher I was just picturing
that the wineglass wash are they made
out of flesh washer like my broke ass
does not comprehend the thought of a
person washing dishes and I'm like a
dishwasher made of human flesh those new
loci reminded me of hotforwords you
remember that Channel know how I
remember that you would have been too
young no this was like back in like 12
years ago YouTube days there was this
channel and actually she kind of
disappeared like there's kind of a
mystery surrounding her disappearance
but anyway she was kind of she was
really popular at the time and she like
was this like had that down angle with
her camera where you could see her
cleavage at all times and she to have
like you know glasses on sometimes she
was sexy and she would just like
describe define words really was she
like a plant like lonely girl yeah oh I
don't know if it was a plant but um yeah
she was she was definitely popular on
YouTube I actually never watched the gym
I keep talking about some but maybe both
is is too young like we all ain't gonna
go super techie but wait you didn't know
she was she was too maybe she just
wanted that road I don't know Oh
sometimes I mentioned always never ever
in your life I have no clue that is yeah
I don't know but you are young both so
[ __ ] you good thank you you're welcome
so what are you guys quarantine routines
like like you have one or you just kind
of like whatever are started doing yoga
what what how do you do this poor thing
has changed you yeah I don't know if I
like that change enough so I like it but
but with all life comes balance right I
started doing yoga but also I started
drinking more I picture you doing yoga
in that exact outfit
that glass a lot he would just see
restaurant valuations yeah just knock
tonight I'm gonna stay at home but I
didn't feel like three days straight I
think in the morning like I look up some
YouTube video like ten minute morning
yoga [ __ ] this [ __ ] has me thinking
about my day and what's my intentions
for the day do you think is she like a
[ __ ] actually really impressed you
breast a breast they did have you
started to moved yeah so there's that I
am oh [ __ ] let me show you guys
something real quick what up what up let
me show you some [ __ ] movie magic I
also broke the [ __ ] out of my bed so one
in the floor and the leg out where
though you're one another in my bedroom
Shh so I'm a whole new one so if you
guys are listening audio only you're
gonna have to watch the video yeah she
just turned her palace into a green
screen into a bedroom and I don't know
why it's real anymore and then I got a
rug now so there's that and then back to
luxury Jesus Christ and your cat's gonna
pee all over that rug nobody's good yes
been me at all that's gonna be part of
your routine allow me to take you to my
other quarters and we'll take you to
like anyone's like Emma no man just just
keep talking Nicky's good alright
alright okay so tip I know you were
texting your like a week ago about not
having a routine
how is have you been like developing a
new one we signed up for master class
we've been like watching any O's how's
that yeah well Tiffany has a dual su
news deal she's in the news area senior
I could see your lips moving I get the
sound like two seconds later yeah yes
how's going on there
right now well I can't I don't know when
you're gonna finish your sentence so I'm
like yeah but anyway um I still have not
developed a routine like how I would
like to it's still like in my thoughts
but I haven't done it but anyway like my
actual day-to-day has just consisted of
like oh it's the package that's gonna
come in today it's the home project work
on and then that's my whole day like I'm
just you did the stairs the other day
those looked great yo Jeff you should
put it on your green screen your
background so we can see yeah yeah let
me enjoy it yeah okay yes so for those
of you listening at home TIFF had she
moved into a new place and she's been
home decorating and recently she shared
a picture in the group chat of their the
staircase that she redid where she took
a wallpaper and on each individual stare
like remodeled the [ __ ] out of that
stair and it looks so good it was like
each step is tropical yeah you guys are
crazy
like I like and Tiff's are so good at
decorating I built a bed yesterday and I
sort of got I have to be put in a
hospice care now you guys oh my god I
killed you would dude I always have to
hire somebody oh my gosh okay the rest
of it it looks so good MMX I'm so extra
extra proud of this corner right here
and then you can't see it but the bottom
step IV matched the pattern so looks
like it looks yeah it was a the Aspen I
didn't that's so awesome that's really
cool I love it well I you know even
that's a routine though so to have like
something that you're looking forward to
every day you're like okay tomorrow
the wallpaper package comes in it
looks just like her though so pretty I
can't wait for your housewarming yeah
thank you
oh my gosh I'm so it's like god I can't
wait if you yeah especially like
honestly this entire process of fixing
up our house like it has given me so
much more confidence and my my skills
like in my vision of like what I can
imagine and then actually make it come
to life like I feel so [ __ ] proud of
myself because all these little pieces
like for example just today I'm gonna
I'm gonna airdrop a photo of the living
room cuz our couch just came in and I
was really skeptical if this like TV
stand and if the couch is gonna go
together with the blinds I picked out
like all these little elements that once
I see it all together and I'm like oh my
god it actually worked like I'm yeah I'm
happy like us which is just a feeling
hmm what'd you do with your old
furniture oh girl it is all in the
garage oh my god the whole plan was to
try to sell everything before we moved
into the new place but then I just kept
feeling like I had time or like I got
months like I can do this later I could
do it later and next thing I know we're
moving and I'm like yeah oh crap like
yeah girl I'm trying to get rid of it
I'll come to it all yo send us some
pictures Yeah right
why won't here stems we got first dibs
yeah mm-hmm no I'll show you some I'll
send you guys some pictures but I'm
trying to get rid of this stuff cuz we
don't have a girl like half of the
garage is taken up with that holy TIFF
what's your process for like having a
vision for I'm making the thing come to
life do you go on Pinterest or do you
create like a like a mood board or
anything and then like pick things from
there or you just kind of like go online
and shop and then whatever looks cool
you buy it and then hope it comes
together well so I did try having a
Pinterest mood board but then like I
don't know
but the way my brain works like I need
to see it how it's gonna be for it to
work
for in my head so instead of that like I
stopped using Pinterest and I just
thought of like elements and pieces that
I really really gravitated towards and
then I picked a color and I went with
that color scheme I went with the with
the style so I'm kinda aiming towards
kind like bohemian a little bit what
kind of mid-century sorta and like kind
of like I don't know a little bit of
everything so what I do is when I'm
shopping for a certain piece like a big
piece I'm looking at it and I'm trying
to envision it with other pieces that I
have selected where I'm like oh maybe
this might look good this might look at
like for example for my TV stand like
I'm gonna look this is a TV stand that I
ended up going with okay so I always
couch colors trying to look for things I
know I love it let me get out of the way
and I was like oh my god it actually
works it looks so good
we got for the TV stand oh I was
thinking like okay I really want
something with pattern and like it looks
like a little like collecting INDD point
with this I almost went with a yellow
one I almost went with the red one like
I don't know my I'm all over the place
but yeah I just got one piece at a time
I keep telling y'all to hit me up
because my family owns a furniture store
yeah let's send the website Gina no yes
you told her what she wants what you
want from a website and then she'll see
if she can find it for a good price oh
thanks so like she's fulfilled your
dreams yeah she's gonna write a check up
know a drink
fabula what's your routine but like
those I've been washing my face more
than usual myself like sometimes I don't
get to that second wash of the day like
I always do in the shower but just
sometimes it doesn't happen so I'm
starting to get a skin routine which is
really great but what I'm most excited
about is like you guys know I had just
quit my job like two months ago and I
also
ready to like dive into the world and
then it seemed like everything stopped
but in the last two weeks I not only
have gotten like more work than ever but
I'm like actually doing my dream jobs oh
yeah I'm like very very happy of miss
like exactly what I wanted to do like
two years ago when I came to LA and yeah
so work has been like really choppy like
you never really know when you're gonna
get an email calls are kind of at weird
times so there hasn't been much of a
routine for me but every day I'm getting
a little bit of work done and then
trying to relax for at least 9 to 12
hours a day so it's you know what for me
I've been just trying to learn how to
like take a step back and enjoy free
time dude I totally relate to that so
you're reading this book collective read
a lot and the book that I'm on now is
called the 4-hour workweek and I'd heard
a lot about it yeah have you read that I
do basically the sparknotes version of
it okay okay just i like the activity of
reading it like calms me so i try to
read at least 10 pages a day or a
chapter a day of a nonfiction book and
this is the one that i'm on and I've
always been I think Bose and I relate
the most to this that like busy busy
busy lifestyle like I like feeling busy
I like feeling productive I get a lot of
self-worth from that but you know the
past couple years have been super
stressful where I just feel like
completely overwhelmed and like my
schedule rules me rather than me ruling
my schedule and so even though I I felt
like I already did most of the
principles in 4-hour workweek that I had
heard of people talking about I still
wanted to give it a go and one of the
biggest game changers for me happened in
the first couple chapters where he talks
about like being productive rather than
busy to like really think of what
activities you're doing that are like we
do a lot of busy stuff like I'm
answering emails and I'm taking phone
calls and I'm organizing blah blah blah
but like how many of those are really
productive and when I first heard it I
was like well I mean everything is
productive right but then after reading
more
kind of goes into defining the 80/20
rule and how like yep 80% of your
productivity comes from 20% of what
you're doing and then you can apply it
everywhere where it's like 80% of your
money comes from 20% of the stuff that
you're doing and how to like really
streamline it so that you're only
focusing on the stuff that's getting 80%
of the stuff done and I started applying
that and I've been working like on one
or two main things a day that's like
things that contribute the most to my
income and my happiness and well-being
and then the rest of the time I've just
been relaxing and it's been so weird
I've like been playing Animal Crossing
wait Nikki and then act when you apply
the 80/20 rule afterwards don't you find
that you still have the same amount of
result from your proclivity that you yes
you're getting the same exact amount of
results but you're spending so much less
time and yeah and less stress amazing
it's amazing because like I yeah Nikki
and I are similar we're like we
literally looked at our schedules and
we're like Jesus Christ I have to wash
my hair today and what we've got use
well I like to use a subscription
service because I don't have the time to
go out and be busy buying my shampoo and
conditioner and one thing that makes it
really easy to get your shampoo and
conditioner delivered to your door in a
customized way key word there is their
function of beauty and I love their
service like genuinely freaking love it
it lasts forever by the way we got this
shipment in like June of last year 2019
and it's I still have it I'm still using
it and what I like most about it is that
you get to pick what scent you like best
and then you get to pick like what your
hair goals are so for me it was volume
and shine and it really delivered that
in the product and then you get to pick
like what color you like and custom it
customize it and it says like function
of lemo you can put function of Nikki
woods balancing and then I'm gonna show
ya oh I like what super breeding the
thing yeah yeah Eddie here add a new
diet Dana what Diana Diana Ross diner
who knows
a fortune girl right the end away yeah
Natalie named Vanna White dime gasps
dude all of us are just in love with
this service and we all had different
hair needs and it like worked for us so
I I really really like it I'm a huge fan
so to get started right now you can go
to function of Unicom slash big moon to
take your four-part haircut profile quiz
and save 20% on your first order don't
spend another minute in hair misery go
to function of beauty calm / big mood to
let them know that we sent you
that's function of beauty calm / big
mood whoo you know and yeah I love right
now delivery services delivery yeah I'm
food delivery food that's right what we
all need right now because apparently
everyone just wants to go as grocery
stores ransack everything and not only
do I want to eat but I want to eat
healthy ata lfy healthy healthy and the
best way to do that is by using daily
harvest you're so prepared roll I
freaking love this I love this song
I haven't tried this movie yet this is
the men cacao what do you have there
Gina which ones that I got mango mango
and greens oh this one strawberry and
effort apricot last night it was so good
oh my gosh I'm excited about this one
it's a cauliflower rice and pesto so
it's super super healthy they come
frozen you can microwave them or you can
cook them stovetop and it especially for
anyone that's busy in the morning make
your cup of coffee with your Keurig make
your daily Hargis sit down get to work I
freaking love it so if they deliver it
right to your door everything stays
fresh in your freezer until you're ready
to enjoy it you can actually order them
in increments of like 924 like you can
order a whole bunch for the month for
the week and get them delivered fresh
each week they never use preservatives
added sugar or artificial ingredients
and they're committed to minimizing
their environmental impact
that's right they're in the process of
transitioning to a hundred percent
compostable recycling package and our
50% of the way there already they are
almost already done so guys you can get
your own daily harvest oh my god wait
what
are $25 I love to order this right now I
just I just ordered a new package with
our coat discount I want them to send us
more it's so good I love the smoothies I
like the breakfast waltz breakfast balls
are my favorite but as a person they
literally come in just everything you
need you've dumped it into the blender
so go to daily harvest calm and enter
the promo code big mood for $25 off of
your first box that's right
yes Coco big move for $25 up your first
box at daily harvest calm did it hard a
second I'm bi G M ood big quibbling fine
yeah I like I like fully ordered a new
order of daily harvest cuz they were so
good right you know what on C's Nicki
have you been doing a little shopping
too lately that's something I've gotten
into recently recently I'm because I do
not that I'm not good at fashion and I'm
also you know what unfortunately I'm
gonna be real with you guys I feel like
I don't care as much about my appearance
as I should especially it's like kind of
an on line figure so one of my goals for
this year was be in the best shape that
I could be at the end of the year and I
think that's mentally physically and
like also athletically oh yeah so I'm
exploring changing up my fashion a
little bit cuz you guys know I was
working I was working full time jobs
before at one point I was working in a
law office so the only time I've redone
my wardrobe in the past two years was
for like fancy stuff that I could wear
in a law office and it's just not me so
I I've been shopping lately and I've
been finding this more like kind of
alternative like a little like Goffe
kind of reminds me of like the cybergoth
face I had when I was younger and I
bought so much stuff from like dolls
kill and I love it I feel like I'm
finally taking ownership of like my
wardrobe identity which I've never
really done before yes I love that for
you then that's so awesome I think that
a fully contributes can I feel the same
way as you were I was always more about
like efficiency and productivity I don't
know if you're getting a theme here but
I'm like oh I need
like work done so I didn't really care
about my appearance unless it was for an
audition because of the roles that I was
going out for their like you know you
kind of have to like look a certain way
but I really you know didn't care aside
from that I never wore makeup if I
didn't have to but I realized that when
I started taking over the taking
ownership of your appearance and like
actually making an effort to like play
around with things there's more like a
spirit of play you know and like
discovering that I actually got a lot
more confidence from that because when
you walk into a room you're owning
yourself a lot more like you're owning
what you look like you're you're like
almost proud because you put some work
into it and that's so true that yeah
some flashbacks to when I first started
making money like finally I was getting
a paycheck that I could actually spend
on myself and I went on a shopping spree
and I bought a whole bunch of stuff and
then just like from then on I started
feeling great about myself because I'm
like hell yeah I finally get to just how
I want because I've always been so broke
I could never afford the things I wanted
right you guys it's true it does you're
making money off this like playing with
our wardrobe own clothes I guess I don't
you know the funny thing is that I have
been wanting to buy so much stuff
because one thing that I missed the most
in this quarantine is shopping I miss
malls so much but like for some reason
like I'll sit there be like yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] buy something to make
myself feel better and I'll put
everything in my cart and I'm like I'm
too lazy to look for more and I haven't
bought anything at all
that's good Jeana that means you didn't
really need those things yeah true but
yeah like I want to be more
irresponsible so gonna have prettier
things like that's past week three times
I'm like dude I'm going to donate all my
clothes I'm gonna start all over but I'm
just as you're just completely covered
in diamonds you're like I wish I had
more things more beautiful day
[Applause]
it's not my shoulder I have something
for that action lotta thing I bet you
dimes inna I also love that Gina's like
you guys are making money to spend in
yourself she like has a Gucci purse that
are cute yeah I think they're definitely
really when I'm to go get it
Nikki in the sense that like when you're
so when you're so like hell-bent on
prioritizing work and busy busy busy
I almost see my physical appearance as
like a low tier thing it's like the 1 2
3 & 4 are very very important and I'm
just trying to get into the habit of
making my appearance just a little
higher on you know the totem pole yeah
and I think it's just so much I think
maybe even my time management is bad
because sometimes I'm like just doing
something else and I'm like oh it'll
only take me 10 minutes to get ready but
I'm like bro like let's do 45 you know
spend some time some self-care treat
yourself
ya know it's definitely a work in
progress for me to just cuz that was so
such a newer faucet of my life like you
and what I've what I find really fun is
the just like playing around I remember
when I say if when you were saying you
first started making money and like
you're like I can actually spend money
on me I remember that first check of
like okay now is the time I got money I
can spend it I had no idea what my
frickin style was so I just started
buying [ __ ] but then I and then I wear
it be like well it's new and it's like
it's in or whatever and it took me a
while to find my personal style but then
like when you find it you're like oh wow
that's like feels better and I feel like
I almost contribute more quality to the
things that I'm doing because I like
that part of me so much - I also like to
think of like what type of person do I
want to be this year and this year was
like all about the type of person that
were sat in PJ's to vet and I like
mixing feel different like when you wake
up you're like I'm a luxurious ass [ __ ]
yeah you are oh you know
you're like you're like a your your
style subtities baby yeah the nineties
and 70s are my two decades I made the
mistake of so when we started when I
started streaming like I would have to
change my clothing every day so
streaming every day so I decided to just
rely on like just whatever Thompson
forever21 they go ahead that works that
works that works jewel tones and I just
bought a bunch of them cuz they were
cheap and they were like you know I need
to switch my every day but I was like
it's quality [ __ ] I really want to just
like get rid of everything and buy like
really good quality like you know just
stay BC this but also like everyday
stuff too because now it's just like all
this cheap garbage I don't really need
right yeah the older I get the more I'm
like yeah quality pieces staple pieces
are so much more worth the investment
than a bunch of fast fashion exceptions
because I also feel like there's a level
of respect like when you respect the
things that you purchased because there
was more value to them you treat them
better and then you feel better when you
have them on rather than like oh it's
just a five dollar shirt that's wrinkled
in my top drawer you know you kind of
feel a collar shirt that's realizing
exactly yeah I got anything how that
works
it sounds so corny but like my favorite
brands of all times Abercrombie and
Fitch I liked it when I was in high
school and as I've gotten older I still
really love it because they have always
been able to produce very high quality
products for a pretty reasonable price
point and because they're you know
demographic is usually like younger
women they're able to sell some of their
stuff for really really cheap and
sometimes they come out with pieces that
are definitely good for like when you're
like early thirties like late 20s like I
just got a whole bunch of stuff the
other day and they'll first put it on
clearance and then they'll put out a
discount code for like thirty five
percent off so now I've got this piece
that's gonna last me for three or four
years because it is really a good
quality and it cost me like 12 dollars
cuz I owe ya I'm looking at a sale email
from them right now it came in 18
minutes ago it's like everything is 15%
off and get an extra 15% off like bro it
is the best quality substitute I love
good quality stuff to make well it's
like the perfect terminus to start
buying ads just pumping it out on
Facebook because you can like I bet I'll
be sitting on Facebook bored of [ __ ] all
day and I'll see that I'm like yeah I'm
gonna buy that like Oh many off Facebook
ads yeah sorry creepy okay guys yeah I'm
ready to nerd out yeah if you which most
of us have you if you have an escort you
get attached to grad school all those
clothes in escort escort escort oh
that's like I have like plenty so many
cars or people why not both mm-hm
both a car person or one was earlier a
human a human dishwasher a human you
know think about your and I think of
boses version like yeah yeah but yeah so
if you you know if you have an escort
it's a tax break because you have to
host a show and so Jeana when you're
streaming like all those clothes because
you're hosting a show it's a business
expense it's harder to do if you don't
have an escort because it that can be
construed as a personal expense as well
right but if you have a you know a
company you're incorporated and you're
like well what I do is entertainment and
I'm hosting it's a write-off and that
means at the end of the year it counts
you can subtract it from your profits
for you I write my hair off I've been
writing my hair off for two years it's
my hair up cuz there's like it's like
five hundred dollars
alright wise when I was varying
extensions now it's a little bit cheaper
but yeah I said five hundred dollars I
read that [ __ ] off so fast that um I
would spend $200 every three to four
weeks like getting it freshened up but
for the actual extensions themselves I
would end up spending about three
hundred and then getting it done was two
hundred oh wow every couple weeks mm-hmm
you do invest in yourself oh that's
great oh no I mean I
can't leave the house looking like that
Nikki I can't it's for me and it's for
y'all because you know y'all be out here
looking at bald-headed bows big fall
both feel hot would you guys still let
me on the show if I was bald oh yeah
yeah oh that definitely okay both you
with a bald head in your gut emo phase
oh my god it likes gage deaf ears
Dickies and [ __ ] I'm like what I kind of
hot I don't know yeah my mom shaped my
head what how did you guys heard it
before no haven't you heard of like how
babies have soft head so you're supposed
to let helmet Oh what home it was a
helmet ball do you mean like like
turning gear and stuff I don't know her
eyes that she molded my head oh my god
yes like water yes she was like gonna be
in my lap and I was just yeah she was
like we go we home shaped this head my
mother yes I kick I wonder I don't think
you can shape at all or anything it's
just the back but it was she was like
dude anymore and ghosts and you Father
meet me as a child just spinning around
my mom's like we gonna fix this I wonder
what it would look like if she didn't
[Music]
you know I wish she did a little more on
the jaw like I could have used like a
you have a good job like okay I like you
jelly yeah your jaw line is a shark dude
I wonder it's really to shape baby's
noses to what like yeah like felt like
like they'll like go like this and like
that like actually massage like a nose
so it could be like more like sharper my
grandmother's always told me like Oh
picture nose appears so that your bridge
can be higher ever since I was a kid
just keep on pinching up here oh they
gonna be lived yeah you're a little
slope G now you got a nice little slow
up dude I got it
wait can you guys see this year I got
slow pumas Maximus I mean I'm never cute
nobody I mean [ __ ] with my slope I
got a better side note you in a front
nose cuz my side nose is pretty straight
and good but then my front nose it's
like kind of wide like you see the
Filipino comes out the opposite I'd
rather have the front nose then like a
little bump so I'm like I'll have that
bump bugs me if he is gonna go down
serious TIFF he has all small features
except eyeballs and lashes yeah you're a
doll I'm not only putting fake ones
bows you know how like in video games
you can like put points in whatever you
want like in your hats and [ __ ] yeah she
maxed out eyeballs and lush this made
nose like the tiniest possible enemies
and then still emailed the devs and was
like um can be this smaller and then she
gets a body and then on boobs she's just
like oh all the way up just maxilla oh
my boy oh my step well oh my god yeah
and you're like a dream Sims character
you are I love you so much
here's our funny it's all true but yeah
back to those like luxury things I was
gonna talk about us in an episode
because I know one of our topics we were
thinking about was like luxury on a
budget but this kind of reminds me of
that where like even well actually what
reminds me of get taking care of
yourself is talking to somebody that I
will listen to you when you're going
through stuff like if you have anxiety
if you have a depression if you're going
through mental health issues who should
they talk to Gina
honestly like three times when I'm in
bed I'm just like God I do not know what
what to do with all these jewels that I
have and all the riches that I have it
stresses me you know so I'm like I need
someone to talk to you because it's
doing them like it's do a number on my
mental status right now right so what I
do is I go to talk space it's an app
that you can download and I love it so
much because it's basically you talk to
a real psych psych psych psych
therapist ecologist their therapist the
therapist they're a licensed therapist a
licensed therapist
you take a quiz and it's and you tell
them like what I want to talk about what
I like I'm stressed out about and then
they'll match you with a bunch of
therapists and you can choose who you
want to speak to and then if you don't
like them you can always you know choose
another therapist and it's so cool
because personally I use it because I
don't like having to hold everything in
and remember and just meet with my
therapist once a month I can message
them all of my long day or I am if I
wanted to if I'm crying I can send them
a voice message I can send up a video
message I can type to them and they
check their phones twice a day and they
they check their I'm sorry
I messaged him and they check their
phones twice a day and they messaged you
back and they tell you what's up and
like what you should do and then hold on
let me pull up the email really quick
Bryce I'm so sorry I love you mm-hmm
and I like it so much because it's so
insanely affordable like what you pay a
month would be to message them non-stop
is what basically what you would pay for
like an hour of therapist face-to-face
time which it's crazy so the bottom line
is that life can be hard and toxics
wants to give more of us or like give us
a chance to get the support that we need
at a price that we can afford so for the
listeners of this podcast you can get
$100 off your first month ways $100
that's a lot of dollars all right yeah
there's a lot of doll hairs that's a lot
of doll hairs um so to match with your
perfect therapist go to talk space.com
or download the app make sure to use the
code moon mo OD to get $100 off your
first month and show your support for
the show that is mood food at Tok
space.com get your [ __ ] together and
once you got your mental health figure
it out you should take care of your
physical health
how TIFF exactly because you can be
taking care of your physical self with
care of so carob is a wellness brand
that makes it easy to maintain your
health goals
with a customized vitamin plan that
helps you feel your best today and
long-term wives so I absolutely love
carob because they give you your so
first of all you take a quiz and you get
to pick the things that you're kind
concerned about or things that you would
like to maintain or be healthier like
for example if you suffer from a lot of
UTIs they will give you a cranberry
vitamin so once you have your quiz all
filled out and you get to determine what
type of vitamins are are right for you
they will send it to you at your home
they will send it to your home and these
tiny little packages and yes oboes has
one for example where it like this is a
dispenser and each each of vitamin pack
has the exact vitamins that are for you
and they also have your name printed on
it too so it's like specific for Bo's
for example she has her vitamins right
there
and so these hello Bo's yeah and so they
make it super easy to take your vitamins
it's on the go like I said they're in
these individually packed packages and
they're also high quality because care
of they use ingredients that you can
actually recognize like for example
organic cocoa pink Himalayan sea salts
and these these individual packs are
also eco-friendly which I really like so
you can throw them in your compost pile
and you can use them too for your plants
and stuff so for 50% off your first care
of order go to take care of calm enter
code fig mood 50 again for 50% off your
first care of order go to take care of
calm and enter code big mood 59550 you
know what going back to the quarantine
routine something that's just helped me
in general because I've been working at
home for like seven years now and when I
first started working at home I know
it's new for a lot of people that have
never worked at home before but when I
first started working at home I thought
I was gonna get so much done because you
know you don't have to do that commute
and you'd often do commute back and so
it's like extra hours that you have to
work but like hours go by so much faster
at home than they do in an office and so
you know you can just talk about pets
you just try to buy it basically
everything
in your house so one thing that I really
that really helped me was having the
very first hour of the day be just for
me where I have my cup of coffee I have
my water and I do like journaling and I
do make sure I do some meditation and I
make sure I do some movement so it's
like movement meditation and something
creative like with your mind and I don't
look at my phone because if I look at my
phone I'm gonna check my email if I
check my email I'm gonna have to respond
to emails if I it just gets you in that
like spin cycle of where the hours just
start disappearing so I don't go on
social media I don't go on and watch the
news I don't watch TV I don't do
anything for anyone else I just like
have that first hour be for me and then
I'm like energized and have like quality
substance to give throughout the day to
everything else that needs my energy
rather than just feel like super drained
all the time plus a second tip that I
would like to pass forward to a new
struggling with the routine dude I don't
know how you do it man I cannot get
along for an hour just 1/3 an hour oh my
god dude I mean I don't like feeling a
lot less recently or good and you know
what am i day good take tugga's consume
my life go on it takes that I do die I
had a tick tock moment I haven't been
back on but I I've been consumed with
like drama channels lately like we're so
bored and there's so much drama going on
in the YouTube world and I'm just it's
like have you guys kept up with this
stuff it's so interesting
it's like tabloids from the 90s and you
know how history repeats itself
it's literally like you know it would be
like the cover it's like Angelina Jolie
8th child question or question um yeah
it's like are Brad and Angelina blah
blah blah and like now that same exact
thing is happening in the YouTube world
I think it's so interesting but it's
like in a clickbait kind of way it's
like Nikki limo starts new channel and
in
leaves her manager or something and it's
so interesting because it's the same
tablets in the 90s but it's stuff that's
more topical and relevant like to me and
anyone that's in this industry right now
it's so weird it's so interesting no my
whole feed is like how to build assets
in your and here an asset column during
a recession how about tell me I like
researching the stock market I've been
like getting back into investing and in
stocks and getting all that stuff and oh
and I've been like going to the stats
and I'm like okay so you know on average
it's better to invest in a bear but
anyways we are in now because a bear
market on average will only last about
14 months and that's it historically
like if you look back it's never lasted
more than two point eight years and a
bull market on average last four point
five years so if you're buying during a
bear market chances are you gonna make
your money back you know way more than
if you were to invest during a bull
market but then what stocks you invested
well I'm glad you asked
well my whole feed is filled with which
sucks right your feed where cuz I've
been buying my YouTube feed you really
should be bank yeah well we've been
buying we can't say what we've been
buying huh I mean you can't it's not
gonna hurt like say yes because then
someone it's like it's like legal advice
yeah I wouldn't give financial advice
about this later
first week series yeah we need to trade
we need to exchange what we're investing
I'm my I started investing three weeks
ago I already I'm a pterence and it's
gonna keep going up I already know it's
a new list
yeah it just gonna be a list we're gonna
share our list of what starts move
buying into yeah will tell you that
Warren Buffett says that if you are a
novice and that you don't want to like
do any research and any companies or
whatever first of all you should always
do research in companies but if you
don't want to this Warren Buffett says
just bet on the market because
traditionally the market will average
you 10% return on investment per year
over the course of it like I don't you
know that means I just need you to give
me a better hallmark is the left put
money in it just tell us what to search
I'm Robin Hood yeah
good let me give you a book rex
ring
for us watch the videos for us and we'll
be watching do these jewels say that I
can read my husband can't we can't count
read or write girl come on now every
piece of trades so Eugenia I'll take
some diamonds from you Bo's I'll take
some hot Goss and I will trace you to
put some knowledge about stock investing
if you can take some oranges from my
Island yeah oh yeah yeah I took some
oranges for cleaning her weeds yep let's
always hear like cool do you ever say my
dude for beaches are littered with
shells I'm like how are you not
collecting these I believe in nature and
leaving nature untouched as it is okay
Nikki oh wow
as I speak behind my giant mansion that
I probably cut down thousands of trees
for yeah and polished diamonds like we
think those come from [ __ ] hate blood
diets - Rosie are you not an animal
person
I literally bought a switch and bought
Animal Crossing and controllers and
everything and I played it for two or
three days and I just can't I have my
ADHD is so bad so like like cuz not but
I get into Gina because I wanted a like
relaxing game to play and I was like
this is a perfect time to get into it
but I can only play competitive games
like the only time that I care about it
is when I'm literally beating the [ __ ]
out of somebody in the gulags like
that's it true all I care about because
because an animal crossing I can't prove
that I'm better than you at the sticks
like yeah you do it you can what you do
you have to build your town into a
[ __ ] utopia and then you take
pictures of it and then you do like
judge it against other people's houses
and stuff I want to kill Mickey yeah I
want to kill he's named Wade he'll fish
the last time I had an animal class it
was on my ideas and I touched it for
like a month and then I let it
I just forgot about it I'm pretty sure
everyone's dead by now but this is the
only thing that's like cuz all I can
play is war zone and I needed something
different and I'm just saying that I
played the stock market with my turnips
and I'm now a millionaire so get all of
those yeah I well I mean that's what I
did I I bought I bought an I filled up
the entire room
my house with turnips and I would just
wait for a friend and tell me that they
had to stock prices over 300 also Nicki
in Animal Crossing there's a pattern for
the stock market in Animal Crossing it's
really good yeah yeah there is what's
the pattern there's multiple patterns
like they have there's like five or six
different renditions where there's one
where it goes in like it just a straight
line where it's 63-67 the next day then
70 the next day and then it goes back
down and then there's one with rising
prices you can tell the different
patterns with me what it means is the
max price will be on Tuesday or
Wednesday and then Thursday and the
wheat like days after it's completely
like moot but yeah everyone has a
different stock pattern each week and
they have a different base price dude my
friend messaged me his his town was
buying buying turnips for five hundred
and five each it was a [ __ ] bloodbath
there dude Ireland it's like man they're
making real and put out in a game I
couldn't even walk two steps until I got
a [ __ ] announcement someone's coming
in I got a plane to land so much huge
mistake I didn't know any like how it
all works
and I gave my coat out my dodo coat out
on Instagram stories this game anymore
this is like every two seconds it's like
someone's coming to your Island like
damn it thinks so long don't do that
yeah yeah I wanted to bring all my
viewers are like all my followers and
stuff into my my Island with my dodoka
but then like some person posted I've
read it they might be able to check down
here I don't know if it's sure not now
I'm scared but I wanted friends but now
I'm glad I didn't do it because they're
getting bombarded by people and I can't
walk around my last for 24 hours so and
one day but like it was held like I
didn't realize the loading screen took
like 5 minutes each time yeah so I
thought they were just like you know
they just come in and appear on my
Island I didn't know it was like a whole
ordeal yes Gina you trying to play some
valour int this week I can't do it why I
have the code I'm in and everything that
game is so damn slow for me I can't do
this how are you serious I'm I'm like 11
years on CS so I'm going
showing it so it's perfect for you I
like be ours oh hey onyx different
language okay so okay like the last leg
and I've just been here quietly like
just looking pretty Valerie like see is
this is Valerie has this way see slow
for me I like be ours I like running
around like hiding out like finding
people so I got like I got early access
in see Valerie and I was like don't
let's play this and within like two
games I'm like well Gina I mean if you
stay alive you get to play more ya know
I would be the first time I played I was
talk kills this board Oh serious I got
to see this Gia
oh right now alright yeah we will be
playing on the same team guys there's a
there's a game that just came out it's
called Valerie
it's from the creators of league of
legends they haven't created a new
[ __ ] game in 13 years
so it's a pretty big deal but what they
did was they made it so that you can
only get access to the game if you watch
a twitch stream that's playing Valerie
and people have been watching for 12
hours 36 hours and like not getting keys
so it's very very exclusive to get in on
it I think only 50,000 at first it was
25,000 and so I'm not even sure if I
don't know now that elites are making
sense cuz I get tweets on my timeline
that are like how long I got to watch
pokey lean play Balor it until I play
and I'm like I don't know do why you
watch I don't understand and that makes
sense yeah so and so these twitch
streamers that like there's the guy
summit usually averages I want to say
like 30,000 viewers he's been reaching
like 200,000 concurrent viewers no
problem just because of this game so
it's like a really big deal in the
gaming community the eSports community
yeah it's it's it's really interesting
I'm curious where this is gonna go in
the next couple of years
hmm you say something
did you say something yeah yeah I wanted
to know how Steve is oh he is home is
cold for him where the Chauvin a tuxedo
the wedding movement succeed oh yeah so
funny because I needed help to zip up my
dress and so Katie and Isaac we're
downstairs and I was like hey Casey
can't help me and he comes up the stairs
he goes oh my god right now we're like
middle-aged moms and stuff are wearing
their wedding dress again to show their
husbands and the husband did it oh it's
on the nest
I could probably oh my god that's even
cuter yeah that is sleep-talk trends I
did the one where you surprise your
husband naked while he's [ __ ] a
videogame I told the girls this in our
group chat okay so last week on big mood
I talked about how we've been going
through a dry spell right because like
if we just weren't like the timing was
off he wanted it when I was tired and I
wanted it when he was tired and
vice-versa and whatever so like we both
wanted it really bad we're horny
[ __ ] we just couldn't like get
the timing down so I saw this trend on
tick tock where you surprise your
boyfriend or your husband while they're
playing video games and Steve plays
video games all day long on the computer
so I was like perfect
I'll surprise them in the middle of the
day but people buck butt naked and he'll
jump all over me it'll be a cute
reaction and also we'll get sex well it
backfired like no [ __ ] other so I get
all like you know get all naked I do my
hair all trashy because he loves it
trashy like I put on big old hoop
earrings I put on like bunch of makeup
lashes yeah hooker to the to the max
like Oh as Max Nikki limo hooker as she
could possibly go hi and I had my bun
and then in the kitchen which was on the
way to his office
I dropped the robe and I'm like getting
all nervous and I'm like he's gonna
[ __ ] love this I can't wait for this
reaction I go in there and he doesn't
notice me at first so I go closer to him
but he had his headphones on right so
like he's like in his game and I'm like
okay go a little closer and he doesn't
notice me still and then I get closer
and all of a sudden he turns around and
he gets freaked out of his mind he's
like
he was like what are you doing oh my god
what are you doing what are you doing
and I was like surprised and then he was
like it's like why would you do this are
you filming this why are you filming
this is this a prank
he's on IG stories of my being story is
this live and I was like is this all
that you're noticing right now is that I
scared you and he's like oh no I know
that you're naked too but like why are
you and I was like that's your reaction
and I got like shook and I started
crying and then he felt terrible I was
embarrassed because I'm like [ __ ]
naked thinking he's gonna like get
really excited and he was lit like he
was livid but not not out of anger out
of fear like when he gets scared his
first like instinct is protective and
anger and like you know punch whatever
is scaring him and so he got angry and
then then he realized immediately that
like what was you know going on and then
also because he ran a prank she on our
channel for so long like his YouTube
channel was all pranks people would
always be trying to prank him on camera
so he was just really hyper vigilant
about getting pranked whenever he saw a
camera I didn't know what was going on
so he thought one he got scared and two
he thought he was being pranked somehow
even though I'm like butt naked looking
you know looking ready for sex he
thought he was getting pranked which I
understand looking in hindsight um so he
felt terrible I was like so just shook
there was the opposite response of what
I thought would happen and I had to like
cool it for a little bit but then a
couple hours later he surprised me and
we did it you drive smells / we did a
night achieve eventually good my god I
have to ask what game was he playing I
don't know the first-person shooter
games it was a first-person shooter game
but I don't know it could have been one
of your one of y'all's games at your
thighs Gina is it wait is he playing
[ __ ] mine words out he know we should
have streamed with Steve his love that
oh my god I should
yeah I guess be hilarious dude yesterday
when I was cleaning up Gina's Animal
Crossing island he was jealous he's like
I wish I had my own husband so I could
come play with you so you know that you
play together yeah oh yeah then we'll
bring them on okay well I'll Street that
[ __ ] - let's do this so once I'm flying
some Star Wars ass game sometimes he's
born not like I don't know density I
don't know they'll be so fun yeah let's
just [ __ ] do it guides link in the
description
yeah you everyone go watch their stream
thank you thank you my live stream oh
this is only this is only my pocket
change yeah like I've you know I'm kind
of running a little bit lighter today
cuz it's kind of heavy
oh yeah you did with a little pour a
little scared there yeah this was one of
yous in heaven you were both oh this is
my Simpson sacrum oh well Lenny is
getting laid during this quarantine yes
yeah finally
yeah I'm waiting for some pipe
dude buzz vu tell your man like two
weeks ago this was the longest in our
entire relationship that we've ever gone
without sex it was almost a month which
is the one I've gone in my life I think
we'll be in a relationship if that was
me I would just be like I did do that
cuz you know I was mostly PMSing so
hormones were out playing and I was just
like I'm not beautiful but he was a it
was just like it reminded me of like a
dad like showing me like why would you
do that why you scare the [ __ ] out of me
like I'm sorry I wanted to be
are you guys what have you guys been
eating during this quarantine Donuts
daily harvest yes yes excellent yeah I'm
eating a lot of hoes mates - yeah I've
already put on three pounds that yeah
that's a lot is that a lot that's a lot
for me that laughs do you want that's
look like it's gotten to the point where
I'm like show ate three pounds every day
I'm just gonna eat all the carbs I don't
want a thing of guacamole yesterday I
would so excited doing yoga
yeah pretty much but also oh my god yoga
makes you feel like it stretches parts
you'd even know that could stretch Gina
exercises for the first time
yeah reacts to exercise a live stream
like dominoes are loving walkable is not
a carb Gina so Eco nuts on that it's
blood tortillas it's a few chips over
there yeah that's a card cousin yeah or
like my girlfriend has been making like
homemade dumplings and she sells like
she'll deliver to you I bought like
three bags of them they're so good
hey it's getting pretty bad I was
getting pretty bad guys well you're
making me really hungry Gina so I think
I'm gonna go make some food now this has
been an awesome chat everybody tune into
Gina bows and Steve's live stream yes we
come TIFF and I will be decorating our
houses so you can get tuned in to our IG
stories for that Mickey will be
decorating models in real life and
enamel dressing which looks really
similar to my real life house I'll be on
full Easter outfit so cute pisses me off
it was adorable
thank you oh wait I gotta go back to my
house now I gotta go back home alright
we love you guys thank you so much for
watching thank you to all our sponsors
let me - and thank you to our sponsors
yo Shunzhi harvest
kenya dude we're still alive I love you
talk space
saying yo now's the perfect time for
talk space because you're stuck at home
talk to your [ __ ] therapist get your
[ __ ] together by the time this is all
over you're gonna be primed and ready to
eat some ass eat yes some ass she's the
big mood gold is you already